الاشتباكات والاحداث مستمره والتصعيد بين
قوات فاجنر وقوات الجيش الروسي مستمر يقول
الرئيس بوتين هي خيانه عظمى وطعنه في
الظهر وترد قوات فاجنر بان بوتين مخطئ في
اخر التطورات الان يقول موقع ريبار
العسكري ان اربعه ارتال عسكريه لقوات
فاغنر قوامها ما بين
150 الى 400 عربه عسكريه تقريبا تسير هنا
كما تشاهدون على باقصى سرعه على طريق ام 4
طبعا ما بين روستوف وموسكو وسبق ان تحدثنا
ان مروحيات تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استهدفت هذه القافله ربما هنا في
استهدفت حركتها على الطريق وهناك انباء عن
اغلاق ايضا الطرق جنوب موسكو في هذه
الاتجاهات طبعا اجراءات احترازيه اخرى قد
تتخذها السلطات هناك من بينها ما اعلنه
عمده موسكو عن تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه
لمكافحه ما وصفه بالارهاب وايقاف جميع
الفعاليات الجماهيريه ايضا في العاصمه
موسكو وتنفي السلطات حاليا ان تكون هناك
حاجه لاعلان الاحكام العرفيه لكن النيابه
العامه حذرت الاحزاب ووسائل الاعلام من
مقاله تشويه المعلومات الرسميه المتعلقه
بمكافحه الارهاب كذلك هناك صور في اخر
التطورات ايضا لقوات احمد الشيشانيه هي
قوات خاصه شوهدت في روستوف الان هنا فيما
يبدو انها متجهه لمواجهه مع قوات فاجنر
التي تسيطر على معظم المنشات العسكريه في
المقاطعه
طبعا ربما هذه القوات تكون قوات احمد
الشيشانيه عادت من الجبهات في اوكرانيا
وليس من الشيشان على اعتبار ان جمهوريه
الشيشان الروسيه التي تشاهدونها هنا هذه
الجمهوريه تبعد نحو يعني 600 كيلو متر على
الاقل عن روستوف عودا على بدء دعونا نذكر
ان هذه الاحداث بدات عقب تصريحات لقائد
فاجنر تحدث فيها عن معسكرات تابعه له هنا
في الجبهات في اوكرانيا تعرضت هذه
المعسكرات لقصف
بمروحيات
كما نشاهد هنا ووصفها قائد بانها طعن من
الخلف اتهم وزير الدفاع الروسي بانه وصل
الى روستوف بنفسه لاعطاء الامر الذي اسفر
عن مقتل عدد كبير من قوات فاغنر بحسب
قائدها طبعا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اصدرت
بيانات نفت كل تلك الادعاءات تلك كانت
البدايه ما ت هو تحرك عسكري لقوات فاجنر
من جبهات المعارك اذا التحرك عكسي من
جبهات المعارك في اوكرانيا باتجاه
المقاطعات الروسيه المحاديه لاوكرانيا
بالاخص مقاطعتي
واجهه رئيس الاركان طبعا وفق اتهامات قائد
فاجنر واجه هذا التحرك بقصف هذه العربات
عربات حتى وهي بين السيارات المدنيه على
الطريق كما يقول قائد اذا ما هو الوضع
الان حاليا فيروسطوف تقول قوات فاجنر انها
سيطرت على هذا المطار العسكري هنا في شمال
غرب
المقاطعه وهي مدينه روستوف التي تقع على
نهر الدون هنا وعلى كامل المنشات العسكريه
الموجوده هنا في هذه المقاطعه هناك ايضا
انباء عن حركه دبابات اليات عسكريه ايضا
كما شاهدنا قبل قليل تحركات القوات
الشيشانيه الخاصه الش عسكريه في المقاطعه
اوقفت حركه المرور كان هناك حديث عن اسقاط
قوات فاجنر مروحيتين هنا في المقاطعه
اسقطت قوات فاجنر مروحيتين
عسكريتين خلال هذا اليوم طبعا وخلال هذه
المواجهات التي جرى جرت هنا في اروستوف
ايضا في المقاطعه الاخرى الحدوديه الاخرى
مع اوكرانيا اوكرانيا
يبدو ان قوات فاجنار سيطره ايضا على عده
مرافق اساسيه عسكريه خاصه اعلنت ان نحو
180 من قوات حرس الحدود استسلمت لها هنا
في بوغاييفكا كذلك نشرت مقطع فيديو لاسقاط
طائره
مقاتله من طراز سوخوي هنا هذه الطائره كما
تشاهدون قالت انها استطاعت اسقاطها ايضا
اشتباكات خفيفه ربما لقوات التي عبرت هذه
المقاطعه كما ذكر مراسلنا امين درغامي قبل
قليل وابعدت ربما نقاط الحدوديه على طريق
ام فور انفجارات في عده مناطق ايضا في
المقاطعه صور لحريق لمستودع نفط في
المقاطعه السلطات دعت المواطنين الى تجنب
الطرق العامه بسبب الحراك العسكري هناك
حديث كما ذكرنا ان قوات فاجنر تعبر عبر
طريق الام فور في هذه المقاطعه في هذه
الساعات حاليا يبدو ان التسعيد سيستمر
اكثر من ذلك قائد فاجنر وعد باعدام وزير
الدفاع في الساحه الحمراء بموسكو وقال انه
سيدمر كل من يقف في وجهه الا زمن الامر